Ce qu'ils faisaient à l'époque [Musique] [Musique] étrangère, c'est qu'après avoir
terminé l'autopsie, ils gardaient le
cerveau, ils gardaient le matériel qu'ils
avaient examiné et le mettaient sur une étagère
et disaient d'accord, peut-être dans
longtemps, dans 50 ans.  peut-être que
quelqu'un viendra en savoir plus
sur le cerveau, ce que nous savons maintenant,
merci
lorsque le patient est décédé, ils sont venus ici et
ils feraient euh, la
plupart des institutions danoises faisaient
partie d'une psychiatrie d'État, donc
c'étaient des hôpitaux psychiatriques d'État
et euh et  il n'y avait pas
de gens de l'extérieur qui
posaient des questions sur ce qui se passait
dans ces institutions publiques, les patients en
psychiatrie avaient très peu de droits, ils
pouvaient obtenir, vous savez, se faire soigner
sans aussi sans
dire oui à cela  traitement particulier
des cerveaux étrangers uniques dans le sens où ils
étaient des
patients, cela se produit chez des patients d'il y a
de nombreuses années, alors qu'ils
n'étaient pas traités avec le
traitement que nous avons actuellement, mais ils le sont
dans ce sens qui nous permet d'observer les
changements.
[Musique]